like anytime I see a person on the right
and the left come together and talk now
they just in their minds they just have
the most ridiculous caricatures of the
others opinions and nobody even knows
how to have a conversation anymore and
do you think those caricatures have
become worse over the past 10 or 20
years I would say that the last 5 years
has been unique because I think for the
first time ever we have the internet and
we've got a lot of money and power
behind pushing certain types of content
to people that is basically having them
view the same type of material over and
over and over and over and over again I
don't think we've ever had a setup on
the planet where you've got a profit
incentive on a worldwide thing that
encourages people to only consume one
type of content like I think if you go
back like even 15 20 years ago before
the internet was as big you still had to
be somewhat grounded because you had
neighbors you had your local community
you see people at church you see people
at the union you see people at school
but now you can have whatever insane
opinion you have you can go online and
probably find a community of like 5,000
people that have it regardless of how
insane your opinion is and I think that
kind of thing is relatively
unhealthy